Marvel readers have been familiar with Venom
for decades, but the half-alien anti-hero
is only just now making his standalone big-screen
debut.
From who's playing who, to the comics you
need to brush up on, here's everything you
need to know before you see Venom.
A symbiote story
Also known as the Klyntars, the symbiotes
are a race of extraterrestrial, fully sentient
parasites.
They live by cocooning living organisms and
feeding off their adrenaline, sucking hosts
dry before leaving them for dead.
The Venom symbiote is unique in its species
for desiring long-lasting bonds over quick
kills a trait which makes it an outcast.
Making its first appearance in a string of
1984 comics, the Venom symbiote originally
attached itself to Peter Parker in the form
of a black Spider-Man suit.
While Peter initially enjoyed the benefits
of the symbiote, he worked to rid himself
of it after he discovered its villainous nature,
eventually driving it away by exploiting its
weakness to loud sounds.
A new host
The best-known human half of Venom is Eddie
Brock, played by Tom Hardy in the 2018 film.
Created by David Michelinie and Todd McFarlane,
the character made his first full-fledged
appearance in a 1988 issue of Amazing Spider-Man.
In the comics, Brock is a once-respected reporter
who lost his job as an indirect result of
Spider-Man's crime-fighting.
Specifically, he's fired after a high-profile
story about a serial killer's true identity
is discredited after Spider-Man nabs the real
culprit.
Furious and seeking guidance, the Catholic
Brock takes refuge in a church the same church
whose loud bells Peter successfully used to
separate from the symbiote.
After they encounter each other, Brock and
the symbiote bond over a shared hatred of
Spider-Man and Venom as we know him is born.
Existing outside of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
the Venom movie significantly tweaks Brock's
origin story, removing the Peter Parker element
and setting the action entirely in Brock's
home city of San Francisco.
In the movie, Venom bonds with Brock without
ever encountering Peter Parker as you can
tell from the lack of white spider markings
on the movie Venom's suit.
Adapting the source
While the Venom movie is an original story,
it's based on two distinct Marvel comic arcs.
The first, 1993's Lethal Protector, is a six-issue
story that sees Spider-Man and Venom arranging
a truce, with the latter agreeing to leave
New York for San Francisco.
Venom takes up a role as a Bay Area antihero,
eventually teaming up with Spider-Man again
to fend off five new villainous symbiotes.
The second chunk of source material is 1995's
"Planet of the Symbiotes", a five-issue arc
which also follows Venom and his allies as
they work to stop a worldwide symbiote invasion.
Combine the two together, and you get the
movie's story of a brutal west coast superhero,
protecting San Francisco from his violent
fellow aliens.
The Life Foundation
In the comics, the shady organization of survivalists
called The Life Foundation was formed during
the Cold War by people who believed that the
world was headed for a nuclear holocaust.
To ensure the survival of civilized life on
Earth, the foundation built a massive fallout
shelter for survivors or, at least, for those
wealthy enough to buy themselves a space.
To protect the shelter and its inhabitants,
the Life Foundation kidnapped Venom and used
him to create five new symbiotes: Agony, Phage,
Lasher, Scream, and Riot, all of which get
bonded to Life Foundation employees.
Reportedly, the big bad in Venom will be the
formidable Riot, latching himself primarily
onto Riz Ahmed's character Life Foundation
boss Carlton Drake.
Dreams of Carnage
Venom's most famous symbiote nemesis is Carnage,
an unhinged offshoot of Venom that latches
onto the psychotic killer Cletus Kasady.
Though Sony has tried to keep his involvement
a secret, Kasady is reportedly being played
in the film by Woody Harrelson though that
doesn't necessarily mean that Carnage himself
is showing up.
Speaking to Collider, Harrelson said his appearance
in Venom is more of a setup for the future.
While the actor did not confirm he was playing
Kasady, he hinted at the tease - nature of
his role, saying,
"I'm in a little fraction of this movie, but
I'll be in the next one, you know?"
She-Venom
Michelle Williams stars in Venom as Anne Weying,
who in the comics is a hotshot lawyer and
Eddie Brock's ex-wife.
The movie makes tweaks to their relationship,
making her Brock's current girlfriend as opposed
to his ex.
Much like Cletus Kasady, Anne is another character
with some secret significance.
In the comics, Weying becomes the character
She-Venom, gaining the powers of the symbiote
after Brock allows the two to bond.
Williams has already made it clear that the
movie Anne will be no pushover, but will she
really transform into She-Venom?
Probably not in this one.
More likely, she's in the movie as a seed
of what could come.
If Venom does well enough to warrant its own
sequels, you can bet we'll see more famous
symbiotes taking turns in the spotlight.